Me había graduado de la universidad apenas dos años antes.
Hasta ese momento,
todo lo que sabía del ébola era a través de un breve artículo
que había leído en la universidad.
Me di cuenta de que la enfermedad era tan grave
que ese corto artículo bastaría para convencerme
de que yo también debía irme en cuanto supiera de un caso de ébola.
Pero cuando finalmente ocurrió, decidí quedarme y ayudar,
al igual que otros valientes profesionales de la salud.
Pero pagaríamos un alto precio.
Muchas personas que estaban en el hospital
se habían transformado en contactos de alto riesgo.
Esto significaba 21 días hasta la enfermedad o la muerte.
Nuestros sistemas de salud eran frágiles,
el personal de salud carecía de experiencia y entrenamiento.
De manera que en las semanas y los meses subsiguientes
el personal de salud se vio seriamente afectado
por la enfermedad del Ébola.
Más de 400 enfermeros, médicos y otros profesionales de la salud
contrajeron el virus.
Lamentablemente, mi amigo el cirujano,
quien había identificado correctamente los síntomas en aquel primer caso
fue una de las víctimas.
El 27 de julio, la presidenta de Liberia
declaró la cuarentena en las zonas más afectadas.
Ordenó cerrar todas las escuelas y las universidades
y suspendió numerosos eventos públicos.
Cuatro días después,
el Cuerpo de Paz de EE.UU.
se retiró de Liberia, de Sierra Leona y de Guinea
a causa del ébola.
En agosto, seis semanas después de la muerte de la enfermera,
cientos de personas murieron cada semana.
Morían en las calles.
Los meses subsiguientes,
el oeste de África perdería miles de personas por el ébola.
En agosto me uní a un equipo
para instalar una unidad de tratamiento del ébola
en el hospital JFK de Monrovia.
Estuve a cargo de la segunda unidad de tratamiento en la ciudad.
Esa unidad era un motivo de esperanza
para miles de pacientes, familias y comunidades.
Mi trabajo no era solo brindar atención médica;
me vi cara a cara con el ébola.
Vivir el día a día con el riesgo de contagiarme el virus del Ébola
durante el brote más agresivo
fue una de mis peores experiencias.
Todos los días contaba los 21 días.
Vivía cada momento esperando la aparición de síntomas.
Me tomaba la temperatura varias veces al día.
Me duchaba con agua clorada
con una concentración más alta que la recomendada.
Limpiaba con cloro el teléfono, el bolígrafo, las manos, el auto.
Toda mi ropa quedó descolorada.
Eran días en que uno estaba solo;
las personas temían tocarse unas a otras.
Todos pasamos a ser potenciales contactos de contagio.
El contacto podía transmitir la enfermedad.
Fui estigmatizado.
Pero si así era conmigo, que no tenía síntomas,
imaginen lo que era para quien sí tenía los síntomas,
alguien que padecía de ébola.
Nos dimos cuenta de que para tratar el ébola de manera eficaz,
era necesario suspender algunas normas sociales.
La presidenta declaró el estado de emergencia en agosto
y suspendió algunos derechos.
Y la policía nacional apoyó nuestra labor ayudando a combatir el virus.
En febrero de 2015, nuestra unidad de aislamiento del ébola
recibió miembros de pandillas.
Se los conocía también como "los chicos VIP" de Monrovia,
que aterrorizaban a drogadictos ocasionales
y cuya presencia podía infundir un gran miedo,
a pesar de que no tenían permiso legal para portar armas.
Fueron puestos en cuarentena durante 21 días en nuestra unidad
y no fueron arrestados.
Le dijimos a la policía:
"Si los arrestan aquí,
dejarán de venir, no recibirán el tratamiento,
y el virus del Ébola seguirá propagándose".
La policía lo aceptó, y así pudimos tratar a "los chicos VIP",
quienes no debían preocuparse por ser arrestados
mientras permanecieran en nuestra unidad.
Durante el brote, hubo casi 29 000 casos en el oeste de África.
Murieron más de 11 000 personas,
entre los que había 12 de mis colegas del hospital JFK en Monrovia.
En junio de 2016,
justo 23 meses después de la muerte de mi primer paciente con ébola,
Liberia declaró que el brote había terminado.
Pensamos que una vez finalizado el brote,
los problemas también se acabarían.
Pensamos que la vida volvería a la normalidad.
Hoy en día, hay más de 17 000 sobrevivientes
en el oeste de África.
Las personas que contrajeron el virus del Ébola
cursaron la enfermedad y sobrevivieron.
Consideramos que la tasa de supervivencia era una señal de éxito:
el fin del sufrimiento para el paciente y el alivio reconfortante para la familia.
Cada paciente que salía de alta era motivo de júbilo,
o al menos así lo interpretábamos.
La mejor descripción del momento del alta,
una extraña imagen del momento que define nuestra vida después del ébola,
fue expresado por las elocuentes palabras de mi mejor amigo y colega
el Dr. Philip Ireland, en una entrevista a "The Times".
Al ser dado de alta, dijo:
"Había un montón de gente en el hospital JFK:
mi familia, mi hermano mayor, mi esposa.
También estaban los médicos y gente de los medios.
Me sentí como Nelson Mandela en 'El largo camino hacia la libertad'
y caminaba levantando los brazos al cielo,
agradeciendo a Dios por salvar mi vida".
Y Philip dijo: "Y vi algo más.
Personas que lloraban, felices de verme.
Pero cuando me acercaba, se alejaban".
Para muchos sobrevivientes del ébola, la sociedad todavía sigue alejándose,
aun cuando ellos siguen luchando por llevar una vida normal.
Para estos sobrevivientes, la vida puede compararse
con otra emergencia de salud.
Pueden sentir debilitamiento articular y dolor corporal.
Con el tiempo, ese sufrimiento va disminuyendo en la mayoría.
Sin embargo, muchos pueden seguir sintiendo dolores intermitentes.
Algunos sobrevivientes quedan ciegos, otros tienen daño neurológico.
Y algunos sufren la estigmatización a diario, de distintas maneras.
Muchos niños quedan huérfanos.
Hay sobrevivientes que padecen de estrés postraumático.
Y algunos no tienen oportunidades de educación.
Hay incluso familias que llegan a disgregarse por temor al ébola.
No hay cura definitiva para la transmisión del ébola por vía sexual.
Sin embargo, existen excelentes medidas preventivas.
Hemos trabajado mucho con las pruebas de semen,
el asesoramiento conductual, la educación sexual y la investigación.
En todo el año pasado, no se registraron casos de transmisión sexual.
Pero algunos sobrevivientes han perdido a sus parejas
por temor a ser contagiados de ébola.
Así es como muchas familias se disgregan.
Otra gran dificultad para los sobrevivientes del ébola
es conseguir una atención médica adecuada.
En teoría, los servicios de salud pública en Liberia son gratuitos.
En la práctica, el sistema de salud carece de financiamiento y de capacidad
para que la atención de salud llegue adonde sea necesaria.
Muchos sobrevivientes tuvieron que esperar meses
para ser operados de ceguera por cataratas.
Pocos tuvieron que revivir la traumática experiencia
de hacerse nuevos análisis de sangre al momento de la internación.
Algunos sobrevivientes debieron posponer o suspender su internación
por falta de camas.
Ni una sola cama para un paciente más.
Esta no es una política nacional ni algo oficialmente aceptado,
pero aún muchos temen por un esporádico rebrote del virus.
Los resultados pueden ser trágicos.
He estado con Beatrice, una sobreviviente del ébola, ya varias veces.
Tiene 26 años.
Muchos en sus familia se contagiaron, pero por suerte ella sobrevivió.
Pero desde aquel día de 2014 en que recibió el alta
ante la aclamación del personal médico,
su vida nunca volvió a ser igual.
Quedó ciega como consecuencia del ébola.
En 2014, el bebé de un querido amigo tenía tan solo dos meses
cuando junto con sus padres fue internado en una unidad de tratamiento en Monrovia.
Por suerte, sobrevivieron.
El bebé tiene ahora casi tres años,
pero no puede pararse, ni caminar, ni hablar.
Tiene un retraso en el crecimiento.
Hay muchas otras experiencias ocultas y muchas historias aún desconocidas.
Los sobrevivientes del ébola merecen nuestra atención y nuestro apoyo.
La única manera de derrotar esta pandemia
es cuando estemos seguros de poder ganar la batalla final.
Nuestra mejor oportunidad es asegurarnos
de que todos los sobrevivientes reciban la atención adecuada donde la necesiten,
sin ningún tipo de estigma y sin ningún costo personal.
¿Cómo podría considerarse que una sociedad se ha curado
cuando la identidad de una persona
se define por su recuperación del ébola?
¿Debería una enfermedad previa, que la persona ya no padece,
ser la suma total de su identidad,
la identificación de su pasaporte
que le impide viajar al exterior para buscar atención médica?
En definitiva, el documento les niega atención médica.
O les impide tener relaciones con su pareja.
O los priva de la familia, o de un amigo, o de un hogar.
O les impide seguir con su trabajo habitual
para llevar comida a la mesa o brindar un techo a la familia.
¿Qué sentido tiene el derecho a la vida
cuando la vida es acechada por el estigma y por barreras que alimentan ese estigma?
Hasta no tener mejores respuestas a esas preguntas en el oeste de África,
no habremos terminado con nuestro trabajo.
Los liberianos son un pueblo luchador.
Y sabemos cómo enfrentar las dificultades, por devastadoras que sean.
Mis mejores recuerdos del brote
están en todas esas personas que sobrevivieron a la enfermedad,
sin olvidar a los dedicados enfermeros, médicos, voluntarios
y demás gente del personal
que pusieron en riesgo su propia seguridad al servicio de la humanidad.
Y algunos incluso perdieron la vida en ese proceso.
En el peor momento del contagio,
una sola cosa nos impulsaba a visitar a diario los pabellones
donde se internaban los pacientes con ébola:
la pasión por salvar vidas.
¿Si tuve miedo durante el brote del ébola?
Por supuesto que sí.
Pero para mí, la oportunidad de proteger la salud de todos,
de preservar la seguridad de las comunidades en mi país y en el exterior
fue un honor.
Y así, cuanto más aumentaban los riesgos, más se fortalecía nuestra humanidad.
Enfrentamos nuestros miedos.
La comunidad de la salud toda, trabajando en conjunto, derrotó al ébola,
y de ese modo...
sé que así
podemos derrotar las secuelas
en nuestro corazón, en nuestra mente y en nuestras comunidades.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)